[Music]
yes
said the dealer our windfalls are of
various kinds
some customers are ignorant and then i
touch a dividend on my superior
knowledge
some are dishonest and here he held up
the candle
so that the light fell strongly on his
visitor and in that case
he continued i profit by my virtue
markham had but just entered from the
daylight streets
and his eyes had not yet grown familiar
with the mingled shine and darkness in
the shop
at these pointed words and before the
near presence of the flame
he blinked painfully and looked aside
the dealer chuckled you come to me on
christmas day
he resumed when you know that i am alone
in my house
put up my shutters and make a point of
refusing business
well you will have to pay for that you
will have to pay for my loss of time
when i should be balancing my books you
will have to pay besides
for a kind of manner that i remark in
you today very strongly
i am the essence of discretion and ask
no awkward questions
but when a customer cannot look me in
the eye he has to pay for it
the dealer once more chuckled and then
changing to his usual business voice
though still with a note of irony you
can give as usual
a clear account of how you came into
possession of the object
he continued still your uncle's cabinet
a remarkable collector sir and the
little pale round shoulder dealer stood
almost on tiptoe
looking over the top of his gold
spectacles and nodding his head with
every mark of disbelief
markham returned his gaze with one of
infinite pity
and a touch of horror this time
said he you were in error i have not
come to sell
but to buy i have no curios to dispose
of
my uncle's cabinet is bare to the
wainscot
even where it's still intact i have done
well on the stock exchange
and should more likely add to it than
otherwise and my errand today is
simplicity itself
i seek a christmas present for a lady he
continued
waxing more fluent as he struck into the
speech he had prepared
and certainly i owe you every excuse for
thus disturbing you
upon so small a matter but the thing was
neglected yesterday
i must produce my little compliment at
dinner and as you very well know
a rich marriage is not a thing to be
neglected
there followed a pause during which the
dealer seemed to weigh this statement
incredulously
the ticking of many clocks among the
curious lumber of the shop
and the faint rushing of the cabs in a
near thoroughfare filled up the interval
of silence well sir
said the dealer be it so you were an old
customer after all
and if as you say you have the chance of
a good marriage
far be it for me to be an obstacle here
is a nice thing for a lady now
he went on this hand glass 15th century
warranted
comes from a good collection too but i
reserve the name
and the interests of my customer who is
just like yourself my dear sir
the nephew and sole heir of a remarkable
collector
the dealer while he thus ran on in his
dry and biting voice
had stooped to take the object from its
place and as he had done so
a shock had passed through marchhyme a
start both of hand
and foot a sudden leap of many
tumultuous passions to the face
it passed as swiftly as it came and left
no trace beyond a certain trembling of
the hand that now received the glass
a glass he said hoarsely and then paused
and repeated it more clearly a glass
for christmas surely not and why not
cried the dealer why not a glass
markham was looking upon him with an
indefinable expression
you ask me why not he said why
look here look in it look at yourself
do you like to see it no nor any man
the little man had jumped back when
markham had so suddenly confronted him
with the mirror
but now perceiving there was nothing
worse on hand he chuckled
your future lady sir must be pretty hard
favored
said he i ask you said markham
for a christmas present and you give me
this this damned reminder of years and
sins and follies
this hand conscience did you mean it had
you a thought in your mind
tell me it will be better for you if you
do
come tell me about yourself i hazard a
guess now that you are in secret a very
charitable man
the dealer looked closely at his
companion it was very odd
markham did not appear to be laughing
there was something in his face like an
eager sparkle of hope
but nothing of mirth what are you
driving at
the dealer asked not charitable
return the other gloomily not charitable
not pious not scrupulous
unloving unbeloved a hand to get money
a safe to keep it is that all dear god
man
is that all i will tell you what it is
began the dealer with some sharpness and
then broke off again into a chuckle
but i see this is a love match of yours
and you have been drinking the lady's
health
ah cried markham with a strange
curiosity
ah have you been in love tell me about
that
i cried the dealer i in love
i never had the time nor have i the time
today for all this nonsense
will you take the glass where is the
hurry
returned markham it is very pleasant to
stand here talking
and life is so short and insecure that i
would not hurry away from any pleasure
no not even from so milder one is this
we should rather cling cling to what
little we can get
like a man at a cliff's edge every
second is a cliff
if you think upon it a cliff a mile high
high enough if we fall to dash us out of
every feature of humanity
hence it is best to talk pleasantly let
us talk of each other
why should we wear this mask let us be
confidential
who knows we might become friends
i have just one word to say to you said
the dealer
either make your purchase or walk out of
my shop
true true said markham enough fooling
to business show me something else
the dealer stooped once more this time
to replace the glass upon the shelf
his thin blonde hair falling over his
eyes as he did so
markham moved a little nearer with one
hand in the pocket of his great coat
he drew himself up and filled his lungs
at the same time many different emotions
were depicted together on his face
terror horror and resolve fascination
and a physical repulsion and through a
haggard lift of his upper lip
his teeth looked out this perhaps may
suit
observed the dealer and then as he began
to re-arise
markham bounded from behind upon his
victim
the long skewer-like dagger flashed and
fell
the dealer struggled like a hen striking
his temple on the shelf
and then tumbled on the floor in a heap
time had some score of small voices in
that shop
some stately and slow as was becoming to
their great age
others garrulous and hurried all these
told out the seconds in an intricate
chorus of tickings
then the passage of a lad's feet heavily
running on the pavement
broke in upon these smaller voices and
startled markham into the consciousness
of his surroundings
he looked about him awfully the candle
stood on the counter
its flame solemnly wagging in a draft
and by that inconsiderable movement
the whole room was filled with noiseless
bustle and kept heaving like a sea
the tall shadows nodding the gross blots
of darkness swelling and dwindling as
with respiration
the faces of the portraits and the china
gods changing and wavering like
images in water the inner door stood
ajar
and peered into that leaguer of shadows
with a long slit of daylight like a
pointing finger
from these fear-stricken rovings
markham's eyes returned to the body of
his victim
where it lay both humped and sprawling
incredibly small and strangely meaner
than in life
in these poor miserly clothes in that
ungainly attitude
the dealer lay like so much sawdust
markheim had feared to see it and lo it
was nothing
and yet as he gazed this bundle of old
clothes and pool of blood
began to find eloquent voices there it
must lie
there was none to work the cunning
hinges or direct the miracle of
locomotion
there it must lie till it was found
found
i and then then would this dead flesh
lift up a cry that would ring over
england
and fill the world with the echoes of
pursuit
i dead or not this was still the enemy
time was that when the brains were out
he thought
and the first words struck into his mind
time
now that the deed was accomplished time
which had closed for the victim
had become instant and momentous for the
slayer
the thought was yet in his mind when
first one and then another
with every variety of pace and voice one
deep is the bell from a cathedral turret
another ringing on its treble notes the
prelude of a waltz
the clocks begin to strike the hour of
three in the afternoon
the sudden outbreak of so many tongues
and that dumb chamber
staggered him he began to bestow himself
going to and fro with the candle
beleaguered by moving shadows
and startled to the soul by chance
reflections
in many rich mirrors some of home
designs
some from venice or amsterdam he saw his
face repeated and repeated
as it were an army of spies his own eyes
met and detected him
and the sound of his own steps lightly
as they fell
vexed the surrounding quiet and still
as he continued to fill his pockets his
mind accused him with the sickening
iteration
of the thousand faults of his design he
should have chosen a more quiet hour
he should have prepared an alibi he
should not have used a knife
he should have been more cautious and
only bound and gagged the dealer and not
killed him
he should have been more bold and killed
the servant also
he should have done all things otherwise
poignant regrets
weary incessant toiling of the mind to
change what was unchangeable
to plan what was now useless to be the
architect of the irrevocable past
meanwhile and behind all this activity
brute terrors
like the scurrying of rats in a deserted
attic filled the more remote chambers of
his brain with riot
the hand of the constable would fall
heavy on his shoulder
and his nerves would jerk like a hooked
fish or he beheld in galloping defile
the dock the prison the gallows and the
black coffin
terror of the people in the street sat
down before his mind like a besieging
army
it was impossible he thought but that
some rumor of the struggle must have
reached their ears
and set on edge their curiosity and now
in all the neighboring houses he divined
them sitting motionless and with
uplifted ear
solitary people condemned to spend
christmas dwelling alone
on memories of the past and now
startingly recalled from that tender
exercise
happy family parties struck into silence
around the table
the mother still with raised finger
every degree
in age and humor but all by their own
hearths
prying and hearkening and weaving the
rope that was to hang him
sometimes it seemed to him he could not
move too softly
the clink of the tall bohemian goblets
rang out loudly like a bell
and alarmed by the bigness of the
ticking he was tempted to stop the
clocks and then again with a swift
transition of his terrors
the very silence of the place appeared a
source of peril
and a thing to strike and freeze the
passerby
and he would step more boldly and bustle
aloud among the contents of the shop
and imitate with elaborate bravado the
movements of a busy man
at ease in his own house but he was now
so pulled about by different alarms that
while one portion of his mind was still
alert and cunning another trembled on
the brink of lunacy
one hallucination in particular took a
strong hold on his credulity
the neighbor hearkening with white face
beside his window
the passerby arrested by a horrible
surmise on the
pavement these could at worst suspect
they could not know through the brick
walls and shuttered windows only sounds
could penetrate
but here within the house was he alone
he knew he was he had watched the
servant set forth sweethearting
in her poor best out for the day written
in every ribbon and smile
yes he was alone of course and yet
in the bulk of empty house above him he
could surely hear a stir of delicate
footing
he was surely conscious inexplicably
conscious of some presence
i surely to every room and corner of the
house his imagination
followed it and now it was a faceless
thing
and yet had eyes to see with and again
it was a shadow of himself
and yet again behold the image of the
dead dealer re-inspired with cunning and
hatred
at times with a strong effort he would
glance at the open door
which still seemed to repel his eyes the
house was tall
the skylight small and dirty the day
blind with fog
and the light that filtered down to the
ground story was exceedingly faint
and showed dimly on the threshold of the
shop
and yet in that strip of doubtful
brightness did their not hang wavering
a shadow suddenly from the street
outside
a very jovial gentleman began to beat
with a staff on the shop door
accompanying his blows with shouts and
railries in which the dealer was
continually called upon by name
markheim smitten into ice glanced at the
dead man
but no he lay quite still he was fled
away
far beyond earshot of these blows and
shoutings
he was sunk beneath seas of silence and
his name
which would once have caught his notice
above the howling of a storm
had become an empty sound and presently
the jovial gentleman desisted from his
knocking and departed
here was a broad hint to hurry what
remained to be done
to get forth from this accusing
neighborhood to plunge into a bath of
london multitudes
and to reach on the other side of day
that haven of safety and apparent
innocence
his bed one visitor had come
at any moment another might follow and
be more obstinate
to have done the deed and yet not to
reap the prophet
would be too abhorrent of failure the
money
that was now markham's concern and as a
means to that
the keys he glanced over his shoulder at
the open door where the shadow was still
lingering and shivering
and with no conscious repugnance of the
mind yet with a tremor of the belly
he drew near the body of his victim the
human character had quite departed
like a suit half-stuffed with bran the
limbs lay scattered
the trunk doubled on the floor and yet
the thing repelled him
although so dingy and inconsiderable to
the eye
he feared it might have more
significance to the touch
he took the body by the shoulders and
turned it on its back
it was strangely light and supple and
the limbs as if they had been broken
fell into the oddest postures the face
was robbed of all expression
but it was as pale as wax and shockingly
smeared with blood about one temple
that was for markham the one displeasing
circumstance
it carried him back upon the instant to
a certain fair day in a fishers village
a gray day a piping wind a crowd upon
the street
the blair of the brasses the booming of
drums
the nasal voice of a ballad singer
and a boy going to and fro buried
overhead in the crowd
and divided between interest and fear
until
coming out upon the chief place of
concourse he beheld a booth and a great
screen with pictures
dismally designed garishly colored
brown rig with her apprentice the
mannings with their murdered guest
weir in the death grip of thirtel and a
score besides of famous crimes
the thing was as clear as an illusion he
was once again that little boy
he was looking once again and with the
same sense of physical revolt
and these vile pictures he was still
stunned by the thumping of the drums
a bar of that day's music returned upon
his memory
and at that for the first time a qualm
came over
him a breath of nausea a sudden weakness
of the joints
which he must instantly resist and
conquer
he judged it more prudent to confront
than to flee from these considerations
looking the more heartily into the dead
face bending his mind to realize the
nature and greatness of his crime
so little a while ago that face had
moved with every change of sentiment
that pale mouth had spoken that body had
been all on fire with governable
energies
and now and by his act that piece of
life had been arrested
as their horologist with interjected
finger arrest the beating of the clock
so he reasoned in vain he could rise to
no more resourceful consciousness
the same heart which had shuttered
before the painted effigies of crime
looked on its reality unmoved at best he
felt a gleam of pity
for one who had been endowed in vain
with all those faculties that can make
the world a garden of enchantment
one who had never lived and he was now
dead
but of penitence no not a tremor
with that shaking himself clear of these
considerations
he found the keys and advanced toward
the open door of the shop
outside it had begun to rain smartly and
the sound of the shower upon the roof
had banished silence
like some dripping cavern the chambers
of the house were haunted by an
incessant echoing
which filled the ear and mingled with
the ticking of the clocks
and as markheim approached the door he
seemed to hear
in answer to his own cautious tread the
steps of another foot
withdrawing up the stair the shadow
still palpitated loosely on the
threshold
he threw a ton's weight of resolve upon
his muscles
and drew back the door the faint foggy
daylight glimmered dimly on the bare
floor and stairs
on the bright suit of armor posted
halberd in hand upon the landing
and on the dark wood carvings and framed
pictures that hung against the yellow
panels of the wainscot
so loud was the beating of the rain
through all the house that in markham's
ears it began to be distinguished into
many different sounds
footsteps in size the tread of regiments
marching in the distance
the [ __ ] of money in the counting and
the creaking of doors held stealthily
ajar
appeared to mingle with the patter of
the drops upon the cupola
and the gushing of the water in the
pipes the sense that he was not alone
grew upon him to the verge of madness
on every side he was haunted and begirt
by presences
he heard them moving in the upper
chambers from the shop he heard the dead
man getting to his legs
and as he began with a great effort to
mount the stairs
feet fled quietly before him and
followed stealthily behind
if he were but deaf he thought how
tranquilly he would possess his soul
and then again and hearkening with ever
fresh attention
he blessed himself for that unresting
sense which held the outposts and stood
a trusty sentinel upon his life
his head turned continually on his neck
his eyes which seemed starting from
their orbits
scouted on every side and on every side
were half rewarded as with the tail of
something nameless
vanishing the 4 and 20 steps to the
first floor
were 4 and 20 agonies on that first
story
the doors stood ajar three of them like
three ambushes
shaking his nerves like the throats of
cannon
he could never again he felt be
sufficiently a mirrored and fortified
for men's observing eyes
he longed to be home gert in by walls
buried among bed clothes and invisible
to all but god
and at that thought he wondered a little
recollecting tales of other murderers
and the fear they were said to entertain
of heavenly avengers
it was not so at least with him he
feared the laws of nature
lest in their callous and immutable
procedure they should preserve some
damning evidence of his crime
he feared tenfold more with a slavish
superstitious terror
some decision and the continuity of
man's experience
some willful illegality of nature
he played a game of skill depending on
the rules
calculating consequence from cause and
what if nature
as the defeated tyrant over through the
chessboard should break the mold of
their succession
the like had befallen napoleon so
writers said
when the winter changed the time of its
appearance
the like might befall markheim the solid
walls might become
transparent and reveal his doings like
those of bees in a glass hive
the stout planks might yield under his
foot like quicksands
and detain him in their clutch i and
there were sober
accidents that might destroy him if for
instance the house should fall and
imprison him beside the body of his
victim
or the house next door should fly on
fire and the firemen invade him from all
sides
these things he feared and in a sense
these things might be called the hands
of god
reached forth against sin but about god
himself he was at ease
his act was doubtless exceptional but so
were his excuses
which god knew it was there and not
among men
that he felt sure of justice when he had
got safe into the drawing room
and shut the door behind him he was
aware of a respite from alarms
the room was quite dismantled uncarpeted
besides
and strewn with packing cases and
incongruous furniture
several great pier glasses in which he
beheld himself at various angles like an
actor on a stage
many pictures framed and unframed
standing with their faces to the wall
a fine sheridan sideboard a cabinet of
marquetry and a great old bed with
tapestry hangings
the windows opened to the floor but by
great good fortune the lower part of the
shutters had been closed
and this concealed him from the
neighbors here then
markham drew in a packing case before
the cabinet and began to search among
the keys
it was a long business for there were
many and it was irksome besides
for after all there might be nothing in
the cabinet and time was on the wing
but the closeness of the occupation
sobered him
with the tail of his eye he saw the door
even glanced at it from time to time
directly
like a besieged commander pleased to
verify the good estate of his defenses
but in truth he was at peace
the rain falling in the street sounded
natural and pleasant
presently on the other side the notes of
a piano were awakened to the music of a
hymn
and the voices of many children took up
the air in words
how stately how comfortable was the
melody how fresh the youthful voices
markheim gave ear to it smilingly as he
sorted out the keys
and his mind was thronged with
answerable ideas and images church-going
children and the peeling of the high
organ
children of field bathers by the brook
side
ramblers on the brambly common kite
flyers and the windy and cloud-navigated
sky
and then at another cadence of the hymn
back again to church
and the somnolence of summer sundays and
the high gentile voice of the parson
which he smiled a little to recall and
the painted jacobean tombs
and the dim lettering of the ten
commandments in the chancel
and as he sat thus at once busy and
absent
he was startled to his feet a flash of
ice
a flash of fire a bursting gush of blood
went over him and then he stood
transfixed and thrilling
a step mounted the stair slowly and
steadily
and presently a hand was laid upon the
knob and the lock clicked
and the door opened fear held markham in
a vice what to expect he knew not
whether the dead man walking or the
official ministers of human justice
or some chance witness blindly stumbling
in to consign him to the gallows
but when a face was thrust into the
aperture glanced around the room
looked at him nodded and smiled as if in
friendly recognition
and then withdrew again and the door
closed behind it
his fear broke loose from his control
and a hoarse cry
at the sound of this the visitant
returned
did you call me he asked pleasantly and
with that he entered the room
and closed the door behind him markham
stood
and gazed at him with all his eyes
perhaps there was a film upon his sight
but the outlines of the newcomer seemed
to change and waver
like those of the idols in the wavering
candlelight of the shop
and at times he thought he knew him and
at times he thought he bore a likeness
to himself and always
like a lump of living terror there lay
in his bosom the conviction that this
thing was not of the earth
and not of god and yet the creature had
a strange heir of the commonplace
as he stood looking on markham with a
smile and when he added
you were looking for the money i believe
it was in the tones of everyday
politeness
markham made no answer i should warn you
resume the other that the maid has left
her sweetheart earlier than usual
and will soon be here if mr markham be
found in this house
i need not describe to him the
consequences
you know me cried the murderer the
visitor smiled
you have long been a favorite of mine he
said and i have long observed and often
sought to help you
what are you cried markham the devil
what i may be return the other cannot
affect the service i propose to render
you
it can cried markham it does
be helped by you no never not by you
you do not know me yet thank god you do
not know me
i know you replied the visitant with a
sort of kind severity or rather firmness
i know you to the soul know me
cried markham who can do so my life is
but a travesty and slander on myself
i have lived to belie my nature all men
do
all men are better than this disguise
that grows about and stifles them
you see each dragged away by life like
one whom braavos have seized and muffled
in a cloak
if they had their own control if you
could see their faces
they would be altogether different they
would shine out for heroes and saints
i am worse than most myself is more
overlaid
my excuse is known to men and god but
had i the time
i could disclose myself to me
inquired the visitant to you before all
returned the murderer i supposed you
were intelligent i thought
since you exist you could prove a reader
of the heart
and yet you would propose to judge me by
my acts
think of it my acts i was born and i
have lived in a land of giants
giants have dragged me by the wrists
since i was born out of my mother
the giants of circumstance and you would
judge me by my acts
but can you not look within can you not
understand that evil is hateful to me
can you not see within me the clear
writing of conscience
never blurred by any willful sophistry
although too often disregarded
can you not read me for a thing that
surely must be common as humanity
the unwilling sinner all this is very
feelingly expressed
was the reply but it regards me not
these points of consistency are beyond
my province
and i care not in the least by what
compulsion you may have been dragged
away
so as you are but carried in the right
direction but time flies
the servant delays looking in the faces
of the crowd and at the pictures on the
hoardings
but still she keeps moving nearer and
remember
it is as if the gallows itself was
striding towards you through the
christmas streets
shall i help you i who know all shall i
tell you where to find the money
for what price asked markham
i offer you the service for a christmas
gift returned the other
markheim could not refrain from smiling
with a kind of bitter triumph
no said he i will take nothing at your
hands
if i were dying of thirst and it was
your hand that put the picture to my
lips
i should find the courage to refuse it
may be credulous
but i will do nothing to commit myself
to evil
i have no objection to a deathbed
repentance observe the visitant
because you disbelieve their efficacy
markham cried
i do not say so return the other but i
look on these things from a different
side
and when the life is done my interest
falls the man has lived to serve me
to spread black looks under color of
religion or to sow tares in the wheat
field
as you do in course of weak compliance
with desire
now that he draws so near to his
deliverance he can add but one act of
service
to repent to die smiling and thus to
build up in confidence and hope the more
timorous of my surviving followers
i am not so hard a master try me
accept my help please yourself and life
as you have done hitherto
please yourself more amply spread your
elbows at the board
and when the night begins to fall and
the curtains to be drawn
i tell you for your greater comfort that
you will find it even easy to compound
your quarrel with your conscience
and to make a truckling peace with god i
came but now from such a deathbed
and the room was full of sincere
mourners listening to the man's last
words
and when i looked into that face which
had been set as a flint against mercy
i found it smiling with hope and do you
then suppose me such a creature
asked markham do you think i have no
more generous aspirations than to sin
and sin and at last sneak into heaven
my heart rises at the thought is this
then your experience of mankind
or is it because you find me with red
hands that you presume such baseness
and is this crime of murder indeed so
impious as to dry up the very springs of
good
murder is to me no special category
replied the other
all sins are murder even as all life is
war
i behold your race like starving
mariners on a raft
plucking crusts out of the hands of
famine and feeding on each other's lives
i follow sins beyond the moment of their
acting
i find in all that the last consequence
is death and to my eyes the pretty maid
who thwarts her mother with such taking
graces on a question of a ball
drips no less visibly with human gore
than such a murderer as yourself
do i say that i follow sins i follow
virtues also
they differ not by the thickness of a
nail they are both sides for the reaping
angel of death
evil for which i live consists not in
action
but in character the bad man is dear to
me
not the bad act whose fruits if we could
follow them far enough down the hurdling
cataract of the ages
might yet be found more blessed than
those of the rarest virtues
and it is not because you have killed a
dealer but because you are markham
that i offered to forward your escape i
will lay my heart open to you
answered markham this crime on which you
find me is my last
on my way to it i have learned many
lessons itself is a lesson
a momentous lesson hitherto i've been
driven with revolt to what i would not
i was a bond slave to poverty driven and
scourged
there are robust virtues that can stand
in these temptations
mine are not so i had a thirst of
pleasure
but today and out of this deed i pluck
both warning and riches
both a power and a fresh resolve to be
myself
i become in all things a free actor in
the world i begin to see myself all
changed
hands the agents of good this heart at
peace
something comes over me out of the past
something of what i have dreamed on
sabbath evenings to the sound of the
church organ
of what i forecast when i shed tears
over noble books
or talked an innocent child with my
mother
there lies my life i have wandered a few
years
but now i see once more my city of
destination you were to use this money
on this stock exchange i think
remarked the visitor and there if i
mistake not you have already lost some
thousands ah said markham but this time
i have a sure thing
this time again you will lose replied
the visitor quietly
ah but i keep back the half cried
markham
that also you will lose said the other
the sweat started upon markham's brow
well then what matter he exclaimed say
it be lost
say i am plunged again in poverty shall
one part of me
and that the worse continue until the
end to override the better
evil and good run strong in me hailing
me both ways
i do not love the one thing i love all
i can conceive great deeds renunciations
martyrdoms
and though i be fallen to such a crime
as murder pity is no stranger to my
thoughts
i pity the poor who knows their trials
better than myself
i pity and help them i prize love
i love honest laughter there is no good
thing nor true thing on earth but i love
it from my heart
and are my vices only to direct my life
and my virtues without effect
like some passive lumber of the mind not
so
good also is a spring of acts but the
visitant raised his finger
for six and thirty years that you have
been in this world said he
through many changes of fortune and
varieties of humor
i have watched you steadily fall fifteen
years ago you would have started at a
theft
three years back you would have blenched
at the name of murder
is there any crime is there any cruelty
or meanness from which you still recoil
five years from now i shall detect you
in the fact
downward downward lies your way nor can
anything but death avail to stop you
it is true markham said huskily
i have in some degree complied with evil
but it is so with all
the very saints and the mere exercise of
living grow less
dainty and take on the tone of their
surroundings
i will propound to you one simple
question said the other
and as you answer i shall read to you
your moral horoscope
you have grown in many things more lacks
possibly you do right to be
so and at any account it is the same
with all men
but granting that are you and anyone
particular however trifling
more difficult to please with your own
conduct or do you go in all things with
a looser rain
in any one repeated markham with an
anguish of consideration
no he added with despair in none
i have gone down in all then
said the visitor content yourself with
what you are
for you will never change and the words
of your part on this stage are
irrevocably written down
markham stood for a long while silent
and indeed it was the visitor who first
broke the silence
that being so he said shall i show you
the money
and grace cried markham have you not
tried it
return the other two or three years ago
did i not see you on the platform of
revival meetings
and was not your voice the loudest in
the hymn
it is true said markham and i see
clearly what remains for me by way of
duty
i thank you for these lessons from my
soul my eyes are opened and i behold
myself at last for what i am
at this moment the sharp note of the
doorbell rang through the house
and the visitant as though this were
some concerted signal for which he had
been waiting
changed at once in his demeanor the maid
he cried she has returned as i
forewarned you
and there is now before you one more
difficult passage
her master you must say is ill you must
let her in
with an assured but rather serious
countenance no smiles
no overacting and i promise you success
once the girl within and the door closed
the same dexterity that has already rid
you of the dealer
will relieve you of this last danger in
your path
thenceforward you have the whole evening
the whole night if needful
to ransack the treasures of the house
and to make good your safety
this is help that comes to you with a
mask of danger
up he cried up friend your life hangs
trembling in the scales
up and act markham steadily regarded his
counselor
if i be condemned to evil acts he said
there is still one door of freedom open
i can cease from action if my life be an
ill thing
i can lay it down though i be as you say
truly
at the back of every small temptation i
can yet by one decisive gesture
place myself beyond the reach of all
my love of good is damned to barrenness
it may
and let it be but i have still my hatred
of evil
and from that to your galling
disappointment you shall see that i can
draw both energy
and courage the features of the visitor
began to undergo a wonderful and lovely
change
they brightened and softened with a
tender triumph
and even as they brightened faded and
dislimmed
but markham did not pause to watch or
understand the transformation
he opened the door and went downstairs
very slowly
thinking to himself his past went
soberly before him
he beheld it as it was ugly and
strenuous like a dream random as chance
medley
a scene of defeat life as he thus
reviewed it
tempted him no longer but on the farther
side he perceived a quiet haven for his
bark
he paused in the passage and looked into
the shop where the candle still burned
by the dead body
it was strangely silent thoughts of the
dealer swarmed into his mind
as he stood gazing and then the bell
once more broke out into impatient
clamour
he confronted the maid upon the
threshold with something like a smile
you had better go for the police said he
i have killed your master
you